Hãy đồng bỏa lý hợp của ngày mấy bởi thống như một đả thông quanh y quyết giòn Mỹ sản thảo,
ông hộ kể hoạch 2,5 điểm của tổng thống đúng năng trăm,
nhằm chấm giết sau trang tại giải gà ra và cho phép triển hai lực lượng ở địa cuối tế.
Hãy quyết nhận mười bà phy lực thuật trong khi ngà và Trung Quốc bỏ phy lực trắng,
vành kiện cho phép cá nước tham gia hội đồng hoặc bị giòn Mỹ đừng đầu,
được xem là cơ quan chuyển tiếp phục trách tại thiết và phục hội tế tế tại giải gà ra.
Hãy quyết gà của trọng quyền trên khai lực lượng ở địa cuối tế để giám xác quá trình phi quân sự hóa,
gồm tú hội của khi và pháo vi hạ tầm của nself.
Lực lượng hà mắt bác bỏ hí quyết, trên bố sẽ không giả giáp và bỏ cơ trên mở ý là giám hộ cuối tế
mà họ không chấp nhận nửa lạc chiến quyền palestín hong gánh và cho biết sản xam tham gia tế.
Cái nhà qua xác nhận địa đình việc hà mắt tử cho giả giáp có thể giảm tử và chạp với lực lượng cuối tế trong từ lạc.
Mì hảo định nghi quyết mở ra khói để xây dựng một lộ trình từ quyết trong người pelestín
tuy nhiên và kịt người chánh kái tại Isran, gió để cập khả năng hình thành nhận nếu pelestín
nếu khả cắt của chính quyền pelestín đã tiền trên, đầy bố nó quan điểm mà Isran không uống hộ.
Thủ đông bây giờ mình nên tây ra khu phản đối phần à này và tên bố Isran sẽ tiếp tục phi quân sự mòa ra gà ra.